well a huge fire at a chemical plant in
Texas is still burning and will likely
not stop for at least another day you
were looking at pictures of the flames
this morning near Houston the fire broke
out Sunday after flammable liquid leaked
and ignited no injuries have been
reported but people living nearby are
concerned about the possible effects of
the smoke on their health Janet shamlian
is in Deer Park with the latest Janet
good morning I know that area very well
yes and this fire has intensified
overnight viana much more aggressive
than yesterday according to the company
and it may not burn itself out for
another 24 hours it comes as schools are
we opening here amid concerns about air
quality and new information that this
petrochemical company has a history of
violating clean air laws firefighters
say they're making strong headway
battling the flames at the Deer Park
petrochemical plant nearly 48 hours
after the fire broke out we are
controlling the fire and keeping it off
the rest of the tanks the fire started
in a single tank but quickly spread to
six others around it all hold chemicals
used in gasoline nail polish remover
glue and paint thinner fire crews are
using foam to protect other nearby tanks
although the risk of explosion is
minimal we continue to take precautions
to reduce this possibility the thick
black plume of smoke could be seen as
far as 40 miles away darkening the
nearby Houston skyline county leaders
and says people close to the plant are
not in danger the plume of smoke is high
up enough that it is not affecting air
quality residents of Deer Park aren't so
sure
I know smoke rises and it's going a
different direction but obviously things
like the ash and all that just floating
wherever it's all over the car if it's
on the car it's in our lungs we're
breathing it the intercontinental
terminals company and its Deer Park
plant have had their share of
environmental problems over the past 12
years the company has paid more than two
hundred thousand dollars in penalties
for violating clean air and water
regulations at that facility in a
statement ITC's spokesperson Ellis
Richardson told us we
every effort to exceed the regulatory
requirements you can see those flames
behind me it's about a quarter of a mile
way from us the plume rising several
thousand feet up in the air can now even
be seen on satellite imagery this
morning the company has opened what it
calls a claims hotline for anyone who
feels they've been injured by this fire
Nora incredible to see that Janna thank
you